grand a ceremony at the start of a
contentious visit
egyptian president abdel fattah al-sisi
was escorted to the elysee palace
where he was greeted by the french
president emmanuel macron
the leaders discussed regional issues
counter-terrorism
and their shared opposition to turkey's
actions in libya
and the eastern mediterranean macro said
he also raised concerns about human
rights in egypt with sisi
but refused to jeopardize paris's
strategic partnership with cairo
i will not make our cooperation in
defense or economic matters conditional
on these disagreements
first because i believe in the
sovereignty of people and respect for
our legitimate and reciprocal interests
second because i believe that it is more
effective to have a policy of demanding
dialogue than a policy of boycott
that would reduce the effectiveness of
one of our partners in the fight against
terrorism
and for regional stability president
sisi dismissed accusations of
rights abuses it is not appropriate for
you to present the egyptian state and
everything it does for its people and
for the stability of the region as an
oppressive regime
the french president says that egypt is
a strategic partner in the region
but activists say unless cairo respects
human rights
such a partnership is a betrayal of
french values
france is one of egypt's main suppliers
of weapons
campaigners say the sale of arms to
cairo should be suspended
they accuse sissy's government of using
what he calls counter-terrorism
operations
to crush civil society and arrest
thousands of rights defenders
journalists and perceived opponents as
long as the egyptian
president uses the fight against
terrorism to suppress civil society
voice
there is no strategic partnership that
can be done with that government
in 2019 macro visited cairo and spoke
about human rights in egypt
since then relations between france and
egypt have been strained
macro hopes to repair them but
campaigners question the cost
to france's reputation natasha butler al
jazeera
paris